[Aplausos]
símbolo de resiliencia nobel de paz
acusada de ser cómplice de crímenes de
guerra nadie anticipó la profunda
transformación que sufriría la imagen de
la dama como se conoce a la líder de mi
hermana en sang soo choo el asesinato de
su padre el héroe de la independencia
and sand que murió poco antes de que el
país se liberara del yugo británico
volvió personal su lucha por
democratizar mianmar una batalla que
emprendió luego de un largo tiempo en el
extranjero en reino unido- se educó
conoció a su esposo y escribió a sus
hijos por el frágil estado de salud de
su madre regresó al país en 1998
controlado a puño de hierro por el
ejército allí lideró una fuerte lucha
contra los militares durante los 90s que
la consagró como un faro por los
derechos humanos lo que está haciendo la
inversión internacional es poner más
dinero en los bolsillos de una élite
privilegiada que quiere conservar el
poder
las protestas fueron aplastadas y en
santurtzi su cara más visible fue puesta
bajo arresto domiciliario desde 1989
hasta 2010 a pesar de las intermitentes
liberaciones en 2015 llegó al poder con
su movimiento liga nacional para la
democracia para poner fin a cinco
décadas de dictadura militar impulsar la
inversión extranjera y reducir el papel
del ejército en la política pero esta
imagen de resistencia que le dio el
nobel de paz en 1991 se transformó de la
cara más dura del genocidio de la
minoría musulmana rodinia en mianmar
one point one 1.1 millones de rohingyas
huyeron del país por los crímenes de
lesa humanidad perpetrados por el
ejército entre 2016 y 2017 serían
utilizados se extiende entonces al
último la nobel de paz ha sido acusada
de no hacer nada por detener los
crímenes de guerra contra esta etnia
musulmana caso por el que me el mar fue
demandado ante la corte internacional de
justicia a pesar de las acusaciones de
genocidio de debilitar a la oposición y
minar la libertad de prensa su partido
rédito la victoria de 2015 con la misma
bandera con la que prometió defender los
derechos humanos
[Aplausos]